my goal would be in like 10 years to
give up being Kim K and just focus on
this and be an attorney Kim Kardashian
reveals she'll give up being her to
fight for justice it's a different
experience for sure on Sunday night's
episode of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians
Kim delve a little deeper into her
reasoning behind following in her father
Robert Kardashian's footsteps of
becoming a lawyer
I'm really motivated to get to know the
law more and fight for people that
deserve a second chance and it would be
really interesting and fun to have his
like Robert Kardashian attorney a la
plaque that I saw you know on his desk
every day growing up and to have mine
right next to it Kim is putting in the
work flying to San Francisco once a week
to study under her apprentice attorney
Jessica Jackson I won't have time for
events for favors for friends for
literally anything for four years while
balancing her new career and life at
home with her three babies North st. and
Chicago
Kim and Kanye are also about to welcome
baby number four via surrogate
[Music]
like no ad it's like I feel really calm
and at ease I don't know if it's like a
fourth kid thing right or just we've
been through the surrogacy thing before
you just get a little bit more calm as
as they go not that you're not very
famous and beautiful but can I talk to
Chris earlier in the episode
oscar-winning actress Jennifer Lawrence
made a special appearance while Chloe
was painting and of course it was
hilarious never a dull moment
[Applause]